hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now an Australian billionaire has
told Sky News that he'll be opening an
advanced battery plant in Oxfordshire
this year creating up to 300 jobs well
it comes of course just a day after the
battery startup British faults collapsed
and abandoned plans for a gigafactory in
the UK well the iron ore magnet to
Andrew Frost says he'll be expanding the
operations at Williams Advanced
engineering which he bought last year
our economics and data editor Ed Conway
sent us this report from Davos
we're here at the world economic Forum
in Davos a lot of talking of course at
the moment about the battery industry
there's been bad news recently in the UK
about that British Vault uh seems one of
the Great Hopes uh has gone into
Administration well I bring some good
news uh which is that there is a new
battery Factory which is about to be
opened in Oxfordshire this is the first
we've heard of it it has been funded by
a man called Andrew Forrest who's one of
the world's richest men he made his
money through mining his Australian and
he bought just last year a company
called Williams Advanced engineering
it's the spin-off to the famous F1 team
it is going to be making Advanced
batteries the kinds of things that will
go into big trucks potentially mining
trucks and indeed motorcycles and other
applications in the future it's not
quite the same as the kind of
gigafactory that people were hoping for
at British vault in blithe but it does
potentially mean more jobs in the UK
funded by this new Factory here's what
he had to say to us just a little bit
earlier on
last year we started building a large
Factory in kidlington we'll open it in
April it will employ hundreds and
hundreds of new British jobs and that's
only the start I want to expand it from
there then I want to take that
technology to Australia to North America
really stop the British brain drain
really bring the smartest Engineers
which are British and they're scattered
all over the world bring them home bring
them back to us so that was Andrew
Forrest and potentially up to 300 new
jobs to be created in this Factory with
all of the bad news about batteries at
the moment here for once is a little bit
of good news
exactly Ed Conway there now let's take a
look at some of the other stories making
the news for you today and the United
Nations Secretary General has said the
world is flirting with climate disasters
at the world economic Forum in Davos in
his keynote speech Antonio Gutierrez
claimed climate change and the Ukraine
war were interlinked challenges which he
says are piling up like cars in a chain
reaction crash the commitment to limit
Global temperature rise to 1.5 degrees
is nearly Going Up In Smoke
without further action we are headed to
a 2.8 degree increase and the
consequences as we all know would be
devastating
several parts of our planet would be an
inevitable
and for many it will mean a death
sentence
CEO Michael O'Leary says the airline
company will expand its flight schedule
including the addition of new domestic
routes from London to Belfast Edinburgh
and Cornwall well it comes after the
government cut air passenger Duty on
domestic flights from April in a move of
course criticized by environmental
campaigners when asked about the
environmental impact Mr O'Leary said he
didn't feel any concern as the flights
would be on what he called an
environmentally friendly aircraft
nature organizations have said new
legislation could lead to the loss of
Environmental Protections for wildlife
and cost the UK tens of billions of
pounds the retained EU law bill is
designed to make it easier for the
government to replace EU law after
brexit but wildlife and Countryside
links say the change could put hundreds
of laws that protect nature at risk of
being reversed they say weakening EU
laws could cost the UK 82 billion pounds
over 30 years
now total energies have said it expects
to pay an extra 2.1 billion dollars to
the UK and EU from its 2022 earnings as
a result of recent windfall taxes on the
sector in Britain where total is the
second biggest oil and gas producer in
the North Sea the energy profits Levy
increased from 25 to 35 percent which
means they'll pay an extra one billion
dollars to the UK
thousands of environment agency workers
are walking out today due to a pay
dispute with the government River
inspectors flood forecasting officers
Coastal risk management officers and
staff at the Thames barrier are among
those striking after refusing to do
voluntary overtime last month or Unison
says there are major Staffing shortages
right across the agency as salaries have
fallen by more than 20 percent compared
to inflation since 2010
right new analysis from the energy and
climate intelligence unit shows
Renewables have overtaken gas to become
the biggest single source of power on
the UK grid so far this winter or power
generated by winds hydro and solar
reached a new record which means the UK
was less reliant on gas so if we take a
look at our data dashboard we can see
that the Renewables are still producing
just around over 40 percent of our power
today despite the more settled weather
right so discuss to discuss these
findings Ferber is Jess Ralston energy
Analyst at the energy and climate
intelligence unit who carried out this
analysis uh good afternoon to you Jess
good to have you with us um how
significant is this development I mean
it sounds like really good news
good afternoon well yeah it's really
significant and it is good news
um as we know at the moment during this
gas crisis every swoosh of a wind
turbine blade helps us buy less gas
which is very costly and it helps
improve our energy security because
we're not relying on those Foreign
imports of gas to get our power
right so are we keeping up though with
demand do we need much more
um and I'm saying that because just
yesterday we reported on the climate
show that oil and gas licenses are being
handed out by the government and of
course that's not great for the
environment a campaigners say so how
much more do we need
well the UK's current Target is to
Triple or actually just over triple our
current offshore wind capacity and
that's similar to what the the whole of
the EU is aiming for so we do have
strong Targets in this area but of
course as we know targets don't always
mean delivery and the government at the
moment is dragging its feet somewhat on
onshore wind which is actually even
cheaper than offshore wind so if it
starts to get its ducks in a row and
offshore wind help help people build
those wind turbines that we see offshore
and help people build them onshore as
well we can definitely make the most of
this opportunity we're such a windy
Nation you know it seems silly enough to
that's a very good point there and as we
were just saying even on settled days
we're doing pretty well when we were
looking at our data dashboard so where
is Britain as far as a global Renewables
are concerned are we doing pretty well
absolutely so we had early subsidies
back in the 2000s in the 2010s which
really helped to build our capacity in
offshore wind and helped grow those
Supply chains from a smaller startup
type industry to now a global superpower
when it comes to Offshore wind and this
is very much a global Trend so the US
and China and they're investing hundreds
of billions that's billions not Millions
into offshore wind and wind power in
general and that's because they see it
as the next Big Industry they're seeing
it as a growth area and the UK's got a
strong record but we do have a risk of
falling behind if we continue to drag
our heels on some policy and some
decision making particularly when it
comes to onshore wind okay and just how
how do we compare with uh last winter
for example
well last winter was a bit of an oddball
because we were we weren't in the same
sort of gas crisis and we were coming
out the covert pandemic
um so it's a different situation now but
today we know that wind and Renewables
in general are very much helping us to
get over the gas crisis they're helping
to keep bills lower than they would be
otherwise and they're helping to
displace that expensive gas off the
system so we don't have to pay for it
okay some encouragement for the future
Jess Ralston from the energy and climate
intelligence unit good to have you with
us on the climate show thank you
now before we go just a reminder that
the climate Show with Tom Heap is on
Saturday and Sunday that's at 3 30 in
the afternoon and 7 30 p.m in the
evening and we're back tomorrow at 3 30
in the afternoon again see you then